and her children recently arrived at a
comfort displaced people in Mogadishu
she joins about a million others who are
clustered on the outskirts of the city
she came from a farming Village in lower
shibale but here she has no food some of
her children are sick and she is still
grieving the death of her husband and
Childs
my husband and four-year-old child died
on our journey from the village to
Mogadishu
we had to bury them in Shallow Graves by
the roadside
half of the Somali population has been
affected by the drought thousands have
already died two million are internally
displaced While others have moved to
neighboring countries
five rainy seasons have failed in the
Horn of Africa the situation is dire
it's been raining in some parts of the
country but weather experts say the
rains will not be enough to make things
better the rains started earlier than
expected this year so that early onset
of the rain means that most of the
people who are displaced from the Farms
their Farms are not being currently
tendered to or or been found that means
the production may be affected because
before these people some of them try to
go back to their Farms possibly by that
time will be on the second week or the
third week of the rainy season and there
will be not enough soil moisture to take
on their the rest of the crop to to
maturity
this means more somalis may be making
their way to such camps
the U.N Secretary General will be in the
country to help mobilize humanitarian
supports the U.N Secretary General
Antonio guterres will meet with the
president of Somalia he will be talking
to displaced people the last time he was
here uh it was six years ago there was
another drought I saw a lot of somalis
that we have talked to say that they
want to see more action so that they can
be able to break the cycle of violence
and droughts
other comps it started raining heavily
just as people were preparing to break
their Ramadan fast
[Music]
many here will sleep hungry wet and cold
Catherine soy Al Jazeera Mogadishu